[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we had a costume designer Deborah Scott
Academy Award winner I'd worked with
since Titanic she had to kind of have a
foot in both worlds because she had to
design all the costumes for the RDA but
she also had to have the whole other
half of her brain to design all the
costumes and jewelry and hair designs
and hair decoration and everything for
the not be costume design is one of the
most important parts of expressing a
character how a person dresses what
their clothes signify in a clan people
who perform different functions the
leader the fisherman a child that all
these people have a different place in
the clan
researched indigenous people literally
worldwide the environment in which the
Clans live is extremely important to
what they wear
so the American are Forest people they
use things from the pandorian forest the
mankinda are much more adapted to water
you are not good divers maybe good at
swinging through trees but one of the
main reasons that we've made the
garments to completion is the motion of
the Garment
cannot be understood without having the
whole piece so if something's heavy or
feathery or light or stringy or fringy
the way these things move in air
standing in a breeze underwater for sure
which is a huge part of the movie you
really have to have the sample to see
what happens to it I honestly believe
that being able to create the garments
in their full Glory as opposed to just a
piece of 2D conceived artwork is
changing the way that digital films will
be made every Fabric and every woven
piece or every braid and feather they
all have their own life to them they all
move in their own way and that's not
something you can get from just looking
at a piece of artwork and translating
that to a screen we work with water
digital on a constant basis even the
smallest thing like a necklace goes for
scanning where it can actually map it
they read the texture they read the
color and then they use all of that
information in a virtual world
the ability that reality that we're
managing to bring to the movie is 100
going to make it just more real for
everyone
[Music]
[Music]